[Musica]
allora io questa sera vorrei parlarvi di
start up abbiamo già sentito una
testimonianza ma volevo fare un passo
indietro e chiedere anche se non vi vedo
bene quanti di voi hanno una startup in
questo pubblico fate la mano ok non
tantissime allora partiamo da cos'è una
startup una start up non è altro che il
periodo di inizio di avvio di un azienda
che però deve avere due caratteristiche
importanti deve nascere da un idea che è
riproducibile ma anche scalabile quindi
deve avere il potenziale di crescita
ora spesso queste idee nascono da
giovani imprenditori dinamici e
intraprendenti che spesso noi sentiamo
dire si inventano il loro domani il loro
lavoro
il fenomeno del tar tatto come fenomeno
imprenditoriale ha sicuramente un
argomento di cui sentiamo parlare sempre
più spesso e in italia ha una
caratteristica peculiare in italia le
start up non muoiono quindi in curiosità
sono andato a guardare delle statistiche
ed effetti in effetti è proprio così nel
2014 il tasso di mortalità delle start
up innovative italiane era dell 1,7 per
cento nel 2015
questo sale al 3,3 per cento ora per
darvi un metro di paragone negli stati
uniti in media muoiono nove start up su
10 questo è un tasso di mortalità del 90
per cento
quindi voi mi direte fantastico no
in realtà questa differenza in
statistica non significa che siamo più
bravi perché falliamo meno stesso
al contrario
in italia viviamo ancora in un contesto
socio economico e culturale che in cui
il fallimento è etichettato e se viene
etichettato è molto più difficile
ricominciare
quindi è importantissimo non fallire mai
però in altri paesi come ad esempio
l'america che cosa succede il contrario
se tu non fallisce mai gioiello user
cioè non non hai un bagaglio di
esperienze che ti permette poi un giorno
di di avere successo perché il
fallimento di ricalibra quella bussola
interna che sarà quella stessa bussola
poi un giorno a portarti al successo
quindi se noi vogliamo che le nostre
start up abbiano successo al pari di
quelle statunitensi
dobbiamo trovare assolutamente il modo
di permettere ai nostri giovani
imprenditori di fallire senza essere
stigmatizzati dalla società e
ricominciare e ricominciare per tentare
di nuovo quindi che cosa succede a
questo punto che questo questo circolo
vizioso che io ho appena descritto
questo look positivo però non è
possibile instaurare lo se non c'è
l'alleanza delle tre colonne portanti
della nostra società
mi riferisco agli investitori che
concedano in capitale aperto al rischio
al pari degli standard statunitensi in
modo che la start up poi possa essere
attrattiva anche per investitori
internazionali
mi riferisco al nostro network quindi al
nostro contesto sociale che possa agire
da cassa di risonanza delle storie di
intraprendenza e di coraggio dei nostri
giovani imprenditori e mi riferisco mi
riferisco ovviamente alla famiglia il
cuore dell'italia
che possa sempre essere il punto di
riferimento per l'accettazione e
l'esortazione dell'individuo perché
fallire non è facile quindi è un po con
questa lente con questa premessa io
vorrei raccontarvi la storia della mia
start up che è una start up hardware e
si chiama sole mica la nostra missione è
quella di utilizzare la robotica per
mettere in contatto gli spazi interni
chiusi in cui viviamo e lavoriamo la
maggior parte del tempo e gli elementi
della natura
perché questo perché il tutto nasce da
un mio disagio mio disagio che io provai
proprio per la mancanza del contatto
verso uno di questi elementi che era
forse quello che è importante la luce
del sole
però quando ormai qualche anno fa partì
da roma per fare un dottorato
all'università di cambridge che cosa
successe e mi trovai diciamo in una
situazione in cui ecco avevo circa 800
ore sole all'anno
le ho contate in meno rispetto a roma
però quello non era tutto sommato
nemmeno il grande problema il problema
reale rete era che io passavo tutto il
mio tempo in un ufficio dove non entrava
la luce del sole perché era esposto male
e quindi a lungo andare questa iniziale
disagio si trasforma in una vera e
propria depressione che si chiama fismo
affective desorder poi un giorno
feci domanda al primo anno della
singularity university e fu selezionato
da lì la mia vita cambia completamente
perché in modo alla nasa
e quindi per quattro mesi mi unisco a
questo gruppo di altri 79 ragazzi che
come me erano stati selezionati per fare
un corso di full immersion sulle
tecnologia crescita esponenziale quello
che prova importante è che lì ci
insegnarono che l'uso giusto l'uso
corretto della tecnologia è quello di
essere al servizio di quelle che sono
ancora oggi le più grandi sfide
dell'umanità
parlo di povertà differenza di cibo di
acqua potabile e di generazione di
energia pulita sostenibile di cura del
cancro ed è stato durante questi mesi
che io
incontrai anche per la prima volta lei o
stato lele o stato è uno strumento
industriale che allo scopo di mantenere
il riflesso del sole è fisso in un punto
adattandosi costantemente agli
spostamenti del sole che noi percepiamo
15 a tutta l'intelligenza alla base di
questo strumento è proprio mentre ero lì
pensai per la prima volta cavolo
questo forse è il principio è lo
strumento che io posso utilizzare per
portare questa benedetta luce del sole
dentro il mio ufficio qui faccio una
piccola parentesi utilizzare la luce del
sole per illuminazione di edifici può
essere un principio che se usato su
scala globale ha un impatto molto grande
sul nostro consumo totale di elettricità
oggi noi consumiamo e destiniamo il 20
per cento dell'energia elettrica totale
mondiale per illuminare edifici e
naturalmente c'è anche un punto di vista
un po più diciamo individualistico per
cui portare la luce del sole in casa ci
garantisce l'illuminazione a più alta
qualità possibile che è quindi ottimo
per
benessere la nostra salute torniamo un
attimo alla mia storia
quindi questi quattro mesi alla nasa
finiscono e io torno a cambridge lì
ovviamente cominciò a passare tutto il
mio canto libero a cercare soluzioni
esplorare soluzioni per poter portare la
luce del sole nel mio ufficio
quindi compra una stampante 3d la
assemblee e cominciò a stampare quelli
che poi diventeranno i primi prototipi
del nostro elio stato presidenziale caja
che prende il nome dalla dea romana del
focolare finisco il dottorato e la prima
cosa che faccio
torno a roma perché voglio verificare se
caja possa avere un successo o no sul
mercato internazionale
quindi raccolgo un team ristretto di
amici e insieme partiamo e cerchiamo i
primi fondi non ci volle molto per
capire che il l'ecosistema che noi
stavamo cercando
diciamo questa cultura del rischio
questa cultura dell'innovazione legata
ai giovani ancora era agli inizi non era
sviluppata e che quindi dovevamo cercare
altrove
fu così che iniziò il nostro percorso in
california san diego dove siamo stati
parte come una delle dieci start up
selezionate al mondo all'acceleratore
della qualcomm in collaborazione con
tacco stare su un grande network di
acceleratori al mondo oggi e cosa
importante è che ci vedono i fondi ed il
supporto quindi network necessari per
poter avviare questa idea vi dico per
questi quattro mesi che noi passiamo a
san diego
lavoriamo ininterrottamente abbiamo
ingrandito il team abbiamo ottimizzato
il prototipo ma la cosa più importante è
che noi abbiamo potuto verificare la
presenza di un mercato attraverso una
campagna di marketing online che in sole
quattro settimane è praticamente a costo
zero
ci portò 65.000 dollari in pre ordini
quindi li pensavamo ok ha fatta noi
torniamo in italia con questo bel
pacchetto cerchiamo i fondi per avviare
la seconda fase della startup quella
dell'entrata in produzione dello
strumento
purtroppo ci sbagliavamo noi
l'ecosistema lo abbiamo ritrovato più o
meno così come l'avevamo lasciato non
eravamo una startup software che ha una
forma sicuramente meno rischiosa sulla
quale investire
ma soprattutto la nostra idea era troppo
diversa troppo diversa è così che cosa
succede ci perdiamo d'animo un attimino
però è durato insomma un momento ci
siamo subito rimboccati le maniche e
abbiamo detto ok con i pochi soldi che
ci rimangono come ce la giochiamo
quest'ultima chance
e così decidemmo di partire lanciare una
campagna online di raccolta fondi sul
sito in di nuovo questa campagna ad oggi
ha raccolto mezzo milione di dollari
finalmente riusciremo ad entrare in
produzione nei momenti di difficoltà
il ricordo spesso le parole di ryan che
era il direttore dell'acceleratore
straniero quando io gli chiesi ma perché
avete scelto di investire in solennità e
ricordo che lui mi rispose le idee
cambiano i mercati come nascono muoiono
il percorso della start up è pieno di
insidie e solo un team che è in grado di
aggiustare il tiro può farcela
noi non abbiamo investito in solenni da
noi abbiamo investito su di voi
ed è forse con questo messaggio che io
vorrei lasciarvi questa sera forse più
di un messaggio è una richiesta di
fiducia
vi chiedo
di non rifugiarci in vecchi schemi in un
mondo che altrimenti ci dimentica
comunque va avanti anche senza di noi e
quindi vi chiedo invece di dare fiducia
agli imprenditori giovani che ci sono in
questo paese la fiducia della
consapevolezza di poter sbagliare e
fallire e ricominciare senza essere
etichettati ai giovani invece dico non
abbiate paura del fallimento perché
vedete che è solo una parte della strada
che vi porterà al successo
non mollate grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]